on this episode we start 2016 off with a
bang
this is
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 173 of
the ask gary the show and i think a lot
of you know exactly what i'm doing right
now that's right i have turned into a 13
year old girl while i've been away on
vacation and I am now a snap chat Queen
legit I'm excited to be back everybody
mister you hope everyone's off to a
tremendous start in 2016 I had an
amazing time with my family and have had
a very interesting week
at CES in Vegas I think a lot of you saw
the dailyvee I think it probably can can
we like link within ourselves like can I
go dailyvee and then like it pops up
here and as a length of daily vo3
know why even within yourself that's not
true
is that true so I can do a card what is
still shot and go to three okay do that
so much India's here Andrew one of my
favorite all-time interns then Vayner
employee now Jimmy and his thing is here
show them stuff on under the lights in
your way but figure that out
Andrew it's good to see you man oh well
good holiday yeah it's good good nice
and we have a major major announcement
stunwin everybody who you guys know
specially from what do you get invited
to another I thought you know what by
the way you looked a little like Michael
Roman when I first saw it here I've got
Facebook tried to tag me as him that's
unbelievable I saw you just now is like
is that Roma no it's dunwyn stunwin
as you can see Stefan this you can do
can you put a huge sellout alert sellout
alert and is full
Budweiser gear is shifting within the
company on to clearly which we know what
team steve has been a tremendous part of
my team for several years we are super
excited about this next step in his
career and and I just want to thank you
publicly officially for everything
you've done I love you a lot Thank You
Man
and I hope you crush there I'm excited
that I don't have to deal with you as
often I would be
I'd be telling the truth in that I'm
kidding we're all gonna miss some
Indians getting emotional over here
India it seemed very sad
stubborn what you like you played the
kind of India rule for quite a while how
many episodes do we know do we really
kind of know when this is her show you
know what's so crazy this is really
crazy for everybody who's watching who's
been kind of like in my ecosystem for a
long time both my video blog shows had
the same thing happened where like a
signature person got tricked like Erick
Kastner started while every TV and then
right is I know a lot of you know and
then Mott and that happened here - the
first person didn't get as much love as
the second person mob became the biggest
mob when we did t-shirts link it up Mott
was the number one selling t-shirt like
he was and honestly based on a lot of
the chatter I see on social media like
by the way I've been engaging on
Instagram and then I check if they just
added me and of the last 15 people that
I checked who was the last person they
added on Instagram four of them
the last person they added on Instagram
was India and I think it's also because
India started put out some different
kind of content I've noticed India and
so thank you so much brother
d-roc good to see you great job the
other day filming all day and then
staying up to 5:00 in the morning to get
the day levy out and I'm excited to
announce here that d-roc texted me and
nine hey I'm sorry to be dissing you I
don't listen I want a shortcut you on
any year hustle I hear that you know I
hear through the grapevine that you have
in you have ambition for five episodes
of dailyvee next week taking advantage
of me in the rare being here all week
that is a lot of banter to start off the
show and thank you dear Ock for it we're
taping late here so I see we're gonna be
here until midnight tonight banging on
this and so your hustle is real so great
mood excited very excited about a lot of
things going on in 16 and in the let's
get into the show yeah yeah it's been a
while long time Connor asks Gary how
important do you think young people are
two brands both in HR and consumers
I got into it with Connor a little bit
on social media he's awesome though he's
always and I understand where he's
coming from look I think young people
are massively important I think it's
been very obvious if you look at the
four or five social I would say Facebook
and snapchat for sure
Twitter different Twitter was more
tagged wasn't young it never actually
was young it was very tacky tumblr
tumblr Facebook Tumblr and snapchat
three of what I would say are the five
winners the other two being instagram
and twitter instagram twitter twitter
more techie nerdy community than media
instagram more photo different cut like
a lot of different people came together
but if you look at the five social
networks that have popped in in the last
half decade the big billion dollar kind
of players three of them were built by
the young generations thing I actually
and then this is India in my mind so I'm
glad you're here I want to write a piece
around the Facebook and snapchat
generations because I think they're the
only two that's when different languages
were created right
that's what different languages were
created I think there's you know I think
Instagram was in an iteration I don't
think there was a Twitter generation
there's a Facebook generation and now
they're just an app generation guys
there's not a single kid on campus in
America that isn't ninety percent 70
percent 80 percent snapchat with some
complimentary Instagram and then there's
nothing else so that's what's going on
I'm excited about young people's impacts
on brands first I'm kind of ranting
about what him and I were talking about
the set up for everybody for context
we're more talking about this snapchat
kind of thing as far as brands it
depends on the brand if you're gonna
market and sell to 17 to 30 year olds I
think 12 to 20 year olds are very
important for that brand I think people
age down to what school and so I think
that's where they become important I
think if you're selling if you're
building and selling a brand
I don't think of shampoo targeting moms
should or is impacted by the young
generation so I think if your product is
positioned to sell 18 to 30 that 13 to
22 is a bigger and more important thing
than I think people realize that if I
was trying to sell to 18 to 30 I
wouldn't start by marketing to 18 to 30
I would start to marketing probably 16
to 22 there
he might be a hair young so I think they
have a huge impact I think they have a
huge impact that I think brands and
definitely social networks and bands
have a lot of similar DNA that way were
you a little rusty there what are you
thinking I like I like how you're
establishing that you don't give a [ __ ]
about Steve leaving that was but he's
gonna be on the twelfth floor and if you
know anything about vena right now
that's like Antarctica like like India
how many times have you been on the
twelfth floor last year yeah all right
so yeah so CSD cool yeah all right let's
go India Abdul asks Gary how on earth do
you measure your progress on snapchat
Abdul that's very easy it's called how
many views are you getting on your
stories a week ago I was getting 3,000
views now I'm getting 20,000 views on
making progress progress Abdul we're
making progress Abdul let's go Nicki
Nicki gasps Gary how do you tell your
manager that they over set boundaries
for example 9:00 p.m. phone calls and
micromanaging asking for a friend Fred
Nicki look I I don't know I think I
think a lot has to do with you one of
the great things that I value and Steve
is Steve and you know a lot of people
here but Steve Steve was never ever
afraid to kind of give his point of view
I think at times just even scratching
his own itch when the point of view made
no sense but but but him and I created a
great cadence where and and this is
something I try to do with everybody and
the truth is of the six hundred maybe
fifty feel that comfort zone to be able
to say to me like hey you're wrong or I
don't agree or this and that it's up to
the manager and the CEO and the leader
to create a comfort zone to create that
kind of conversation the truth is if
this boss hasn't which most don't and I
and I do recognize that then you just
got to either roll the dice
and hope it goes well I think you've got
if you're gonna go to a boss and you're
gonna say hey you stink
I do think coming with honey before you
come with vinegar really matters I
really think the first taste of a
conversation is quite remarkably
important I do think first impressions
matter
I think first impressions in a
micro-level a conversation matter
I often hedge and I think you guys all
been on the receiving end of this or
maybe not everybody but like like if I'm
delivering bad news or like I want a
little tweak it's usually gonna start
with I love you but or like you're
really crushing this that's coming at
the expense of like I think it's
important and I think you've got to say
look I have empathy for you're managing
a lot of things and they may not be you
might be the only person but anything
you could do to acknowledge that you
have empathy to their situation a lot of
times this is the case I mean this is a
big big common thing hey manager Stefon
like I know that you have tough managers
above you that are probably forcing a
lot of your you know actions but I'm
being affected by it how do we like this
is a problem so look the only thing that
solves conflict is communication it just
is like it just is like and so either
you get and honestly this is a very
weird thing to say
I would also in parallel if it's killing
you if you're super unhappy if you wake
up every morning dreading going to work
I would in parallel start creating some
options for yourself whether you want to
jump into entrepreneurial land or work
somewhere else just something that if it
goes completely terrible like you know
the boss is like [ __ ] you and a week
later you're fired
that you have some hedge because I don't
want to give advice and like I'm getting
emails in a month or like you got me
fired so like you know give that some
thought as well but there is only one
answer I've given you some context for
it I could have made it nice and short
its communication you're just gonna have
to talk to the person about it there's
just nothing else
thanks and yeah drew you know what I
like I like that I said on snapchat like
send in your questions and I'm not using
any of them I like just that completely
was disrespectful instead I was when I
started watching them on video and I
just started like oh crap I really can't
I don't have any app right now to
download music
like Saudi Rock I need to find out a
video down like one of those saving
download apps on snapchat or like one of
the hack apps so I can start downloading
video questions and sending to you guys
for shows Oh drew blood so I won this
bet yeah I need one guru go yeah hey
Gary Vee drew bledsoe coming to you from
Whitefish Montana got two things number
one is a little wager my Patriots are
taking on your Jets today and I'll bet
you a magnum of double-back versus a
bottle of your choosing that my Patriots
even with just my old backup quarterback
plan can take down Ryan Fitzpatrick and
his beard next question for you do you
think there's a tipping point for
Washington wines where the general
population will realize what the wine
world knows and that is that you can get
better value better wine from Washington
than you can from Napa go Patriots
see a lot of fun drew I'll let that play
through so what now the video can pop up
while I'm on or that can happen it can't
click out good so drew listen first of
all thank you for allowing me to win
that bet I expect to get that wine India
can you work with DeMeo to make sure I
get that wine I'm gonna drink it on this
show drew to give you one more shout out
because I think you make wonderful wine
ah you can go back to 2000 when it's
your show sick like two thousand eight
nine ten I've been a long huge advocate
of Washington say why stunwin is is got
a lot of ties to that world you know
drew I think much like things in
business and I'm gonna tie this into a
business environment Oh Mike I think
that what will tip Washington State
wines are the same things that tipped
let's use it into the talk of now it
took ashton kutcher going on twitter and
challenging CNN to see who would be the
first person to a million followers to
tip Twitter main stream I believe what
dj khaled did over november/december
tipped it because I was affected by I'm
like oh great if he's the biggest meme
and he's doing stuff that's in my genre
and the day that I've been seeing for
last six months that snapchats aging up
I this is what it tastes like this is
the mainstream time and I go and then
I'm sure anybody was watching marketing
as I've gone 10
thousand marketers have gone and just
and then they've got groups under them
and so there's tipping points
Khalid for snapchat to go mainstream
even though we've been yelling about its
importance for two years but even I my
actions have been affected by that
bless you India Ashton Twitter and
Washington State
much like the tasting in California
where the California wines in seventy
eight beat the French wines and there
was one writer from Time magazine or I
don't remember exactly what it was that
covered it and everybody in America knew
there'll be a Washington State wine that
comes along that's twenty bucks fifteen
bucks 80 bucks it'll do something
President Obama could have had a
Washington State wine and everybody
raved about it I know he did but but
like but not just I mean Ronald Reagan
put gun lock punch you a California wine
on table but it didn't become a cultural
phenomenon like the next president could
do it and for some reason happens more
likely the Kardashian could fall in love
with the Washington State wine and that
becomes it there's just a million things
and you know there's just a million
things and they can come in many
different directions but it's gonna take
a pop-culture moment drew for it to
cross over something that everybody
knows about
kind of like rose' in the wine world
last three or four years it just started
happening so it's gonna think something
like that something gotta left the field
that we probably can't think of just
like it happens I don't think anybody
was thinking that a 15 year DJ and hip
hop was gonna be the person that kind of
started changing the direction of a
platform that already had a hundred
twenty five million active you monthly
users it's not a small thing
same thing with Washington State they've
been making great wines for twenty years
but it takes a pop culture meme thing to
get it going
Angelo asks Gary I'm thirteen and
writing a nonfiction book where do I
start with marketing at Wattpad is
something I'm very obsessed with a lot
of thirteen to twenty year olds on their
reading females it depends on what demo
you're going after I'm just making you
know I just know that Wattpad has a
thirteen to twenty year old female demo
your thirteen I'm making probably stupid
assumptions you might be running a book
for fifty year olds I don't know but um
medium I would start putting out pieces
of content on medium here's something I
would do immediately if and when and it
seems like the smoke is there Twitter
eliminates the 140 character limit
and goes to 10,000 characters I my
friend would write right now a five to
seven thousand I don't know how I'm
character execution of one of the
chapters you to the book and literally
the second you hear that it's real you
like I would have liked Twitter's blog
I'm push notification to your phone as
soon as it comes right that piece post
it like control-c control-v because
you're ready and then I would take the
link to that tweet and I would hit up
and right click every single tech writer
in the game and say hey I just wrote a
piece because maybe your piece would be
the example they use when they announce
to the world that twitter has gone
through the life as a matter of fact
India I want an exactly 10,000 character
piece of content post
ready for that moment I want you to set
the like I want me to set everybody set
the push notification for it and I'm
gonna have it up immediately and then I
want the comms team to hit up every
single tech reporter about my first post
at 10,000 characters this was a you know
what I was I was very like I was very
business see the last week I felt
sharpest [ __ ] what episode is this I
want a t-shirt 117 just wanted to say
173 the sharpest that's it
question of the day are you tired of me
talking about snapchat yet you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them